but guys this is the most beautiful
thing there's a point where your parents
go from being your parent to your friend
and you're no longer just looking at
them laterally now you're looking at
them horizontally and eventually you're
the one who's looking down as they're
starting to struggle so you have to have
that mindset of realizing there's going
to be an evolution provided you guys
both try to grow together did you know
the first time you had to
figuratively slap your parents upside
the head and be like go to your doctor's
appointment yeah
yeah eye appointment no no but I don't
wanna You're Gonna Go Blind you're
literally gonna do more work for me when
you blind go to your goddamn doctor's
appointment so you make it easier for me
to take care of you if you're watching
right now I want you guys to think about
your loved ones and I want you to ask
yourself this question
so when you think about your entire life
and how you were raised God damn
did your parents do a good job I don't
want you to answer too quickly I want
you to think about the question and
what's your answer
why is it's better when you explain it
okay so this guy comes up to me right
this guy comes up to me it's like
did your parent go do a good job I was
like well
I mean they did the best they could it's
like that's not what I asked you it was
like and he said what I mean is I could
try to perform an open heart surgery and
do my best
somebody's dying
because even though I'm doing my best
I'm not going to do a good job because
that's not what I do now
did your parents do a good job
and boy that [__] me up because it's
true you want to say this I think that's
kids especially immigrants we have an
instinctual and cultural
demand to protect our parents because
they've given so much they've traveled
from far they sacrificed a lot of things
we feel the need to protect them and
that includes criticism and I understand
it and I want to make this clear when I
ask this question I'm not telling you to
not be grateful
I'm not telling you to not respect them
that's not what I asked I'm not telling
you not to look up to them and said you
persevered a lot and I respect that
that's all I'm saying that's not the
question what I'm saying is what you're
saying
through your upbringing were you giving
the optimal circumstances or the
adequate Baseline to be able to
do well to be able to have a life of a
child that you feel is fit and it's
interesting because people will say no
no I won't never say anything but you
notice the life that they try to give
their kids is substantially different
than what their parents gave them the
reason being is because they understand
instinctively some of the things
circumstantially that were bad in their
upbringing and so they don't want to
transfer that onto their kids
our parents brought us into this world
through no desire of our own they made
that choice right and as a result it is
also the responsibility to do the best
that they can in giving us a life
um but through circumstances and like
you know my mom like
I pulled around the highest pedestal
my mom is my homie she's my mom she's my
my Confidant a lot of ways like I love
her to death but I can also recognize
many ways in which
her parenting was terrible
but that's not entirely her fault even
though her parenting was terrible it's
not tough her circumstances war-torn
country did not have an education came
here didn't speak language like just
trying to piece it together doing it on
her own I understand everything
and it makes me respect her but it
doesn't change the fact that as a result
I didn't have any guidance as a result I
had to do so much on my own
you get me and that's still my road dog
I'll give everything to her but it
doesn't change the circumstances and the
reason why I'm saying this
is that when you start to look at it we
are so protective of our parents we
haven't even given us our a chance to
forgive them
or to potentially criticize them in ways
that can make them better
because believe it or not my mom has
improved
she's become a much better parent over
the years you know I'm one of seven
middle child she has I've watched her
change but that didn't come from just
being like Oh go Queen you can never
know there are some tough conversations
that had to happen there was some like
self-reflection about yo this is [__]
up
there's no reason that I've been raising
myself for these last five years it
doesn't make sense I'm telling like what
but that's the circumstance the cars I
was dealt with I'm not going to sit here
and complain about it but we are going
to have certain conversations so that we
can fix things for the future
but also so I can
speak to that resentment or those weird
feelings I have when it comes to my mom
to the things that I've always kept
bottled inside because I want to be a
good son and I've been able to not only
let those things out
but also heal from the and then from
there create a space where she can come
back into my life in a way that's much
better that I can Embrace her in a lot
more ways and then I can be a better son
so this conversation I'm talking about
is one that you may not even have with
your parents because maybe your parent
is not ready to acknowledge the ways in
which they [__] up you know but you
still have to have that conversation
with yourself or someone close to you to
be able to let that stuff out to be able
to acknowledge where you've been hurt
because you can't forgive if you can't
acknowledge you've been hurt or you've
been neglected or whatever the [__] it
is you can't overcome something that you
haven't acknowledged even exists
and a lot of kids
when it comes to their parent have
certain behaviors that if you ask them
about like they snap at little things or
they get annoyed or they avoid their
parents because they don't want to talk
to the reason why that is is there's a
lot of unresolved issues there
and so that's what I mean you can learn
to maybe potentially even fix those if
you have that conversation
so that's what I want to say yeah no I
had to I mean overall I'd have to give
my parents a B minus because
you give them a grade yeah I ain't even
mad at you you took me to the next level
I'd give him a B minus because my my mom
hearing that would be livid because my
mom was a great Aid student
yeah before
we're beating me my [__]
and just for an extra junk don't be
serious but just sorry about oh no man
you're not actually gonna do anything
I'll do it I'll [__] do it I don't
care but yeah like I'd give her a B
minus because overall my parents they
did a good job but they did some pretty
[__] up [__] Caribbean people and
people from
immigrants have a I have a propension
sometimes to raise the weighty raises
the kids is very is very messed up you
know they're raised by insulting and
some people they insult you that's
[__] up they say things that are crazy
my mama I remember my parents used to
say a couple of times yo I don't know
what the I don't know what I did to have
you
I don't know what I had it to have you
funny story is
what do you mean I don't know what I do
I don't know what I did what I did to
deserve you to have you like to have not
to deserve you but hold up so explain
how it happens my dad was always saying
like whenever he was pissed off what did
I do what did I do oh God what did I do
to get you to deserve you save you out
of the time yeah and it's crazy because
I was not doing drugs I wasn't no gangs
I was not doing that I wasn't none of
that none of that [__] none of that
hoodlum [__] never been to prison never
did none of that [__]
at that time I was not even drinking
alcohol you understand what I'm saying
and I got fed up I got fed up one day
one day he said that [__] to me I don't
know I don't know what that did oh Ian
was praying like it was it's like a god
I don't know God I don't know what I did
to have this child right and that's a
[__] up thing to say to someone to
your kid and one time he said that and I
was like that's the last time he says
that without me saying nothing and I
remember one day he said that one last
time he said he said that he said
I don't know oh God what I did to
deserve you and what I told him it was
like well if you don't remember it must
have been boring as hell and I turned
around and ran cause his face changed
and he jumped we ran we ran we ran
and I was that but it's some messed up
[__] to say it's a messed up stuff to
say there's a lot of things that are
crazy yeah you know there's a lot of
things and traumas that I learned from
my parents that I got the trust issues
and stuff like that so yeah the B
minuses for that overall they did a good
job but they did some [__] up [__] and
at the light of those messed up things
that messed up things that they did I
had to
eventually just look at them
and not to them but just to me you know
it was it was for me it was not even for
them whatever they didn't even know
parents tend to not even know at some
point they don't know they don't even
recollect that they beat me they're like
oh we didn't beat you that hard yeah
yeah yeah you did okay
and uh
uh so I had to forgive them
you don't know but you're holding to a
lot of things so whenever you go visit
them you when you snap out it's just the
accumulation but if you don't if that's
because you didn't let that [__] you
didn't let that that that that stuff go
if you don't let that stuff go then then
it's always going to come back and
you're gonna be tense and um so you have
to you know let it out that's it's a
balance yeah in that some of you guys
all you do is complain about your
parents not recognizing their
circumstances or the things that they
did right and the circumstances are
given to them that were probably unfair
okay and then there's also the portion
where like some of you just spent all
day protecting your parents no matter
what even when you're holding to a lot
of resentment the way your parents raise
you and treat you oftentimes results in
how you end up loving other people yeah
that is the reason why people from two
parent households are far more likely to
be able to do relationships and all this
other stuff is because the Dynamics that
they witness in terms of maintaining a
relationship they carry on into their
own lives kids for single parent
households that's a struggle because you
don't even witness it in your
relationship with your parent whichever
one's that home is oftentimes tenuous
because they're so stressed out you have
to find something else so you respect
them for staying and taking care of it
but the stress that they put you under
as a result of their circumstances is a
lot my mom
God bless her barely saw her because she
was working multiple jobs trying to make
ends meet and I always love her but when
she did come home she was so stressed
out from her job that she was hard to be
around she was hard to be around I had a
hard time having any kind of
conversation
I can honestly say this for the first 17
years of my life I had zero
conversations with my mom and when I say
a conversation I mean I sit down she
said something I see something and it's
not like what do you want to eat chicken
no I never had those kind of because she
was it was so much you can't see it
though is so much right but she would
praise me every time I helped out when I
would pay extra I had a job at 16 paying
bills and so my report with her was like
oh if I just help out around the home
and do stuff then you know I'm gonna
have peace and that ended up being the
exact pattern that I engaged in with all
my relationship
that ended up being what it was but that
comes from that environment and I didn't
recognize that until much later on in my
life and what I recognized that I was
able to forgive and let go and now chill
when I'm around my mom but you guys
might also be surprised your parents
have some growing to do and you have an
opportunity to even help that and give
them space to do that some of you like
my parents your parents are not made of
stone they are malleable they can evolve
they can't change I'm not saying it's
gonna be the case but I've witnessed it
have you witnessed it yeah yeah and it's
not going to be necessarily easy either
but I'll see but but but yeah there's a
possibility there would you you said
something crazy you said you the day we
have a man is when you realize when you
do the day you realize you become a man
is not it's not that 18 year old bull
crap it's really when when you realize
that your parents sometimes two complete
idiots okay and just because they didn't
know yeah and the second thing is that
you realize
but we explain the last part what do you
mean like they're too completely well
they [__] up okay you know that ball
were you protecting yeah it's because
you grow up
when you grow up the answer is your
parents
so you think you grow up and you're like
these the one that knows stuff
but sometimes you realize no sometimes
they don't know true they do not know
they're just winging it like anybody
else you think that being an adult is oh
yeah I'm gonna have my [__] together if
not nobody knows what the [__] they're
doing excuse my language nobody knows
what the hell they doing they just
winging it right so does your parents
and on top of that is your parents are
raising you one generation late
they're raising you
how they was raised but you two
generations out
and you're surrounded by other things
that's happening in your generation and
it gets even worse when you're uh
immigrants because they raised you like
they were raised
and you are in a country that is not
there so you're like three generations
apart it's rough right so you realize
your parents sometimes they don't know
what the hell is going on the second
thing is you realize that you become a
man when you're gonna have to take care
of them
you're gonna have to be like yo asking
you is you good yeah I'm good and then
you decipher that that's a lie and
you're like no you're not
what just come here do you know the
first time you had to
figuratively slap your parents upside
the head and be like go to your doctor's
appointment yeah
yeah that's a weird one right yo and I
was like yo yo yo yo how are you doing
something about that [__] that
you're not taking your pills
what the [__] is that to somewhere what
the [__] is and then you like and I look
at my dad like this like what the like
yeah
what the hell is going on what the what
what what's that [__] what it can
you explain to me I almost said can you
explain to me young man
to my bed can you explain to me young
man no no no we're not laughing here sir
we're not laughing yeah sir
hey what is that [__] that you're
not taking your meds bro Mama yeah but
it's because it's because and then
you're just your dad's a Saturday
because
hey stupid you about to go blind go to
your eye appointment no no but I don't
wanna You're Gonna Go Blind you're
literally gonna do more work for me when
you blind go to your goddamn doctor's
appointment so you make it easier for me
to take care of you
I want you to keep your [__] eyes
you're about to go plus dude but I don't
You're Gonna Lose Your Eyes
foreign
it's crazy there's moments like that it
really is an evolution in the change so
I just yeah
I got stories for days but she's like
one of those I'm like
yo
what the [__] is wrong with you when you
can when you you know there's a switch
when you know
wait I just said to you that that [__]
was very damaged as a kid that your
parents call you names and [__]
and then you grow up because no matter
how you're going to try to get away from
it
you're going to become like your parents
okay
and then well you something pisses you
off so much you look at your dad and I
listen here
here stupid and you called him a name
you call this is just not not yourself
we're not [__] around here and like
and that was that has actually helped me
understand their position and the way
they are that's why I didn't give them C
minus I give them extra points
there's some weird stuff out there but
hey you know we we we're about to oh
I mean you can't even understand it I
have to explain this to you lady but
guys this is the most beautiful thing
there's a point where your parents go
for being your parent to your friend and
you're no longer just looking at them
laterally now you're looking at them
horizontally and eventually you're the
one who's looking down as they're
starting to struggle so you have to have
that mindset of realizing there's going
to be an evolution provided you guys
both try to grow together and so have
those conversations yeah you're going to
see a change yeah so uh yeah maybe you
guys have stories yourselves things you
want to share we want to hear from you
in the comments I love I love reading
people's feedback I'm telling you I
actually go through a lot of the
comments and I do check them out so
leave it um if you're enjoying these
videos make sure to like and all that
stuff you want to definitely be able to
spread these but I feel like this is a
topic that's not talked about often so I
want to share that with you that's funny
yo